director zack snyder's four-hour long
cut of justice league has finally seen
the light of earth's yellow sun
when snyder had to step away from the dc
extended universe's all-star team up in
2016
after a tragedy in his family warner
brothers enlisted avengers writer
director
joss whedon to finish the film whedon's
version of justice league was not well
received on release
it was panned critically and bombed at
the box office
the reputation of whedon himself has
also soured among the eyes of
many amid accusations that his justice
league reshoot set was
in the words of cyborg actor ray fisher
gross
abusive unprofessional and completely
unacceptable
booyah fans rallied for warner brothers
to release the snyder cut
a once far-fetched wish that's finally
come true on hbo max
most of the main justice league stars
were quick to come out in favor of the
snyder cut
including jason momoa ben affleck gal
gadot
and ray fisher but henry cavill who
first played superman in snyder's 2013
film
man of steel had mostly stayed silent on
the subject
of the snyder cut until now in a march
18
2021 instagram post henry cavill
congratulated zack snyder on the
fulfillment of his vision for the dc
extended universe the star wrote here's
to you zack
congratulations i know this has been an
arduous journey for you
you kept fighting though i couldn't be
happier to see your vision for justice
league realized
and what a movie it is kevin knows a lot
about fighting to see something get made
he was originally cast in a superman
movie back in 2004
that was said to be directed by the
filmmaker mcgee and even got as close as
having a fitting for superman's iconic
cape but when brian singer took over the
project for what ultimately became
superman returns
he cast brandon rouse in the role cavill
also used the hope never dies hashtag in
reference to his character slogan
in promotion for the film superman's
logo in some versions of comics lore
isn't a big s it's actually the
kryptonian symbol for hope
superman explains the symbol to lois
lane and man of steel
and further elaborates in the whedon cut
of justice league that it takes its
shape
from a river the symbol of the house of
l means hope
embodied within that hope is the
fundamental belief the potential of
every person
to be a force for good when asked about
the snyder cut previously
henry cavill has played somewhat coy
when asked by entertainment reporter
jake hamilton
why he had remained silent while the
rest of the cast joined the call for the
snyder cut
kevill said he declined to speak for a
decidedly unserious reason
he said i miss my mustache which is the
most important thing
and for me it was just a harrowing
reminder that i didn't have it anymore
and so i just didn't want to dig that
wound any deeper
kevill grew the stash for mission
impossible fallout and was legally
prevented from being allowed to shave it
off
during the justice league reshoots well
i knew you didn't bring me back because
you liked me
the results as many know was that
producers spent millions digitally
removing the mustache from
every frame of superman's screen time
the final effect flew supes right into
the uncanny valley for many viewers
so you'd think cavill would at least be
happy to finally have his real face in
the spotlight
in zack snyder's justice league
producers at dc and warner brothers
are currently maintaining that the
snyder cut is not
canon in the dc eu so clark kent's fate
hasn't really changed between now and
2017
but the critical acclaim being thrown at
zack snyder's justice league
may change that as columnist owen
glebermann wrote
in his review of the film for variety
zack snyder's justice league is the
movie that shows us
at last what the dceu could be now that
that's happened to leave snyder by the
wayside seems
not merely unjust it strikes me as
foolhardy
in other words some critics think that
warner brothers should think twice about
ignoring the fan base to which they just
capitulated
henry cavill has expressed interest in
returning to the role
as he told men's health in 2019 the cape
is in the closet
it's still mine check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
dc extended universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one